[Music]
yo this one's for Howard Stern
the greatest of all times the king of
all media the original Pinball Wizard
[Music]
people Rock the [ __ ] house right the
[ __ ] house you gotta Rock the [ __ ]
house
ever since I was a young guy I played
the silver ball from Soho down to
Brighton I must have played them all but
I can't see nothing like him in any
amusement Hall
so I paid a mean [ __ ] panda
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there's a man I found who can bring us
all joy a doctor I found can cure the
boy Dr raphound can cure the pardon
man I found him remove this sorrow we
live in this town let's see him tomorrow
let's see him tomorrow
[Music]
I often wonder what he is thinking
has he ever heard a word I said
look at him
and what is happening in his head
[Music]
and learn at your feet
[Music]
on you I can't opinion from you
from you I get the story
[Applause]
[Music]
what is happening in this
[Music]
shining you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]